las vegas is throwing its biggest fourth
of july bash
ever for the first time the las vegas
strip will get involved with a
massive fireworks show hector mejia is
live outside of resorts world
with the preparations underway tell us
more hector
hey there good morning i found out this
display will be even bigger than what we
normally see on new year's eve and
resorts world here the brand new resorts
world will be one of the seven
launching pads here where production
crews have been on location over the
last three days
and it's all being orchestrated by the
same company that's behind the new
year's eve
display the eight minute 11 second show
will color the sky
in red white and blue precisely at 11 pm
on sunday
with more than 20 000 pyrotechnics of
different sizes
the theme obviously will salute
america's independence but it's also
celebrating the city's
own independence from the coronavirus
shutdowns according to company
fireworks by grucci
[Music]
when we got the final go-ahead from the
lvcva we were tickled pig because one we
knew we could bring something really
special
to to open vegas back up to get that
momentum to get that feeling and to get
that
that invite out to the nation that uh
that we're open
a lot of people are looking forward to
this and to pull this off it's taking 80
pyro technicians installing a lot of
things from equipment to electronics and
computer systems
they're actually working after sundown
to beat the las vegas heat and if you're
wondering
all right so where should i go what's
the best scene in the house according to
fireworks by gucci the fireworks you'll
see over by the strat at the north end
of the strip will be the same thing
you'll see down in the south end of the
strip over by the aria so i mean really
there's a lot of space for people a lot
of people hopping on planes making their
way out here so
a lot of excitement out here reporting
live hector mejia
8 news now back to you guys and i hector
i have a question for you so like
when it's new year's eve they closed off
sections of the strip and let people out
in the street but they're not doing that
this year
for july 4th fireworks is that right
you know what that is a great question i
don't have an answer for you right now
but so far right now it doesn't seem
like they have any planned closures
we don't have any barricades here along
las vegas boulevard if you take a look
everything seems like it's all
normal we have a normal road closure for
that ongoing project happening here
along las vegas boulevard
but as far as those barricades that we
typically see days in advance before new
year's eve
they're not out here at least in this
part of the uh las vegas boulevard
okay so we're not going to ask people
can't stand in the street and watch
fireworks definitely do not sunday night
thank you hector thanks
appreciate that 605 now so if you feel
like going for a drive this weekend
perhaps for the fourth of july
here are some other events for
independence day there's the boulder
city danbury
july third and fourth saturday and
sunday loughlin has a big event over the
riverwalk
mesquite has a light show that'll be at
the eureka casino up
northeast of the town all of those
events start at nine o'clock
henderson is providing some star
spangled fun as well
fireworks extravaganza staff are going
to light off the fireworks at four
different locations in
henderson there's the m resort green
valley ranch out of lake las vegas and
the galleria at sunset
also those shows start at 9 o'clock
sherry and there are parades of course
like the summerlin patriotic parade
returns in person tomorrow morning
saturday morning
at 9 a.m brian loftis and i again
co-hosting the parade along with
mercedes martinez
and j.c fernandez the parade will be a
little bit
smaller than it's been in years past
because of covid
and you know the planning just had to
make sure
that we kept it small and simple the
summerlin patriotic council
summerlin council is doing a great job
though you can check out a full list of
events for the 4th of july on our
website 8newsnow.com
i think there's going to be plenty
plenty of things for people to do
to celebrate our independence nor i
think a good place to watch the
fireworks would be as well
on sunday night would be up on hollywood
on the east side of the valley because
you can see
all of them you can see the strip you
can see downtown you can see whatever
people might be doing in their backyards
uh that would be a and it's a nice place
to kind of get away a little bit so
that's a little sneaky too we've got a
lot of great vantage points
for strip fireworks or stations or
wherever
whoever's putting on a should be a busy
weekend it is going to be so busy and
it's going to be hot